ces nominations vous avez parlé de
monsieur le maire vous avez parlé de
monsieur darmanin on peut pas dire que
ce soit des nominations au mérite parce
que quel est le bilan de bruno le maire
nous sommes désormais la france l'un des
pays d'europe le plus mal géré une
montagne d'endettement des déficits
abyssaux déficit budgétaire en valeur
absolue le pire de toute l'europe
déficit commercial en valeur absolue le
pire de toute l'europe ça passe à 100
milliards au sort de crise il ne fallait
pas faire et notre caillou la cour des
comptes ce n'est pas moi qui vous le dis
que dit la cour des comptes la cour des
comptes dit la dérive des dépenses
publiques en france c'est à peu près un
tiers pour de bonnes raisons pour blake
au vide mais le reste c'est pour le
laxisme voilà le bilan le bruno le maire
et le bilan est le bilan du ministre
d'intérieur c'est 40% sur le quinquennat
des tentatives d'homicides violences
physiques 30 et 1 32%